i'll start to recover and
this afternoon's meeting and before we
start i'd like to confirm which
committee members are
and officers are here
yes chair i can confirm that um for the
committee
we have yourself and councillor ruffa's
chair and then we also have councillor
armitage
councillor potts councillor reader
councillor cooper
councillor ridgeway councillor rouse
councillor powell
councillor mark foster and councillor
shipman and councillor barry
and then officer wise you've got um
adrian kirkham as planning manager and
jim fields then from the legal team alan
martin is your clerk
and myself and martin derbyshire from
the governance team are helping to
facilitate the meeting
thank you as you know we have a protocol
in place for the meeting
it's in a virtual way which i would now
like the facilitator to read out
yes thank you chair so and just to let
you know that this meeting is being live
streamed on the council's website
and all the items will be taken in
public and we'll also be
making a recording for the purposes of
the minutes which i'll start
out this meeting is being recorded
um the recording once the minutes have
been agreed will be deleted
um for committee members please behave
as you would in the council chamber
and speak through the chair please
remain muted unless you're called on to
speak and
to indicate to speak please either raise
your hand or write speak
in the chat bar when you're speaking
please introduce yourself and that
you're a counselor on which ward you
represent
and please keep your cameras on
throughout the meeting
thank you chair thank you item one on
the agenda apologies for absence
all right drag chair just before that
just to confirm um is the uh
stream now live martin
yeah it is the stream's now live sorry
uh
in terms of apologies for absence chair
we've received no apologies for absence
has anyone any apologies to add whilst
we're at the meeting
non-received chair thank you item two is
the declaration of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of
any disposable punary interest and or
other interests
not already on the register of interests
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting
at the appropriate time have we received
any declarations of interest
none have been received chair thank you
item three minutes of the last meeting
we now have the minutes of our tute the
meeting held on tuesday the 20th of
october 2020
are we happy that these are a correct
record
yes move it
i'll second that chair thank you all
those in favor
please raise your hands thank you i seem
to have this wonderful white box on my
screen i can't see half of people there
i can confirm that members are in
agreement
thank you this motion has been carried
item 4 planning appeals lodged and
determined
this moves us on to the main business
normally they would be
asked to consider planning applications
referred to the committee
however as we do not have any in the
position we're to bring forward at this
time
instead we're going straight to the
planning appeals lodged and determined
part of the item for i now call on the
planning manager to explain this report
to us
thank you chair as is customary the
appeals that have been
lodged allowed dismissed
chair are all there in the report and i
appreciate that the decisions are sent
out to all members
in full so i'm sure members have been
keeping up to date with the appeals that
have been coming in
i did feel it appropriate chair with
your permission just to
raise one or two issues around the
appeal allowed at
william thought road at home ward chair
and mr cliff richards appeal
that was determined by way of public
inquiry at the end of september and the
decisions
have been submitted chair members may
well have
had a chance to read this but just a few
points joe just wanted to
raise of interest and it does take some
reading because it
sets out quite interestingly an
inspector's view of the various issues
that were considered that appeal but
what i wanted to just advise members on
share particularly was the
issues that the inspector discussed
regarding the policy context of how
she determined that appeal and in
particular chair the debate that
went on in respect of the publication
draft local plan and the weight to be
attached
to it and also the issue around the
basket of policies that are most
relevant to the determination of the
appeal
just firstly share on the issue of the
publication draft local plan
members will note that the inspector in
determining the appeal
placed limited weight on the publication
draft local plan
which meant that she attributed very
little weight
in effect chair now
going forwards members will know that
the main modifications of the
publication draft local planner now out
to consultation
therefore the weight to be attached to
the publication draft local plan
will alter and we will set out as
officers our views on that in reports
that will be
considered by members going forwards
chair starting in
december ultimately that will be a
matter for
the planning committee to place what
weight they believe is appropriate on
those policies chair going forwards and
we i say we will advise members as
officers of our view but it is
important that members note that and
that
as we go forwards with the local plan
the weight that you are able to attach
to that
publication draft local plan the
emerging vocal plan as
is will increase but you will still need
to be
aware of any objections that have been
made to the local plan under certain
issues
and most importantly how those emerging
policies
relate to the national planning policy
framework and their conformity to it so
we will provide the device chair but
members will need to
place weight on that going forwards i
was also
chair i appreciate cancer armitage may
wish to ask the questions here i'm happy
to carry on or
take the question at this point
councillor armitage uh thank you chet
so basically uh this planning officer
not the planet this inspector has said
little weight to put on it on the
uh new the emerging
local plan i mean it leaves us in a bit
of a quandary doesn't it because
you say members have to say
how much weight they put on it so
you know where do we go from here it's
sort of the blindly
in the blind and didn't another
inspector at another appeal
say that weight should be put on it
so we seem to have had two different
inspectors saying different
ideas and what way to put on i mean it's
hardly much of a guide towards
or making the decision
i don't know which appeal councilor
armitage is referring to chairs in
respect to the
weight to be attached to the plan but
certainly in respect of the
appeal that was dismissed at little
morton road at north wingfield the
inspector in that instance
placed wait on local plan policy any one
of the current development plan
and other inspectors have as members
will note
placed in effect no weight on various
other policies namely gs1
gs6 for example in this instance
mr richard's appeal i suggest
chair take some reading and respect how
the inspector dealt with
those policies in respect to the appeal
at homewood
but i do accept that councilor armitage
what the council arms makes shows that
sometimes inspectors
and perhaps aren't um wholly consistent
with one another
which does make following the various
decisions
and often difficult for us as officers
as well as i'm sure members chair
just in respect of the matter and i i
know
mr shipman wants to ask a question but
the mppf
just set out the three tests of how
what how much weight should be
attributed to emerging plans by local
planning authorities and again members
may well be aware of this but it's
paragraph 48
and the three tests are the stage of
preparation of the emerging plan and the
more advanced is preparation the greater
the weight that may be given
the extent to which there are unresolved
objections to relevant policies
the less significant the unresolved
objections the greater the weight that
may be given
and finally chair the degree of
consistency of the relevant policies in
the emerging plan
to the framework so those are the three
tests that we will
need to discuss and advise members on
going forwards
thank you councillor shipman thank you
chair
um i agree with council armageddon i
mean
ultimately we've got other appeals that
have been uh
dismissed off the back of the local plan
and this one i mean this is just one
where it's the inspector has placed
a different weight to what the other
ones have
i'm i'm unsure as to why that's being
highlighted
that we shouldn't be placing much weight
on the the local plan when ultimately
it's up to this committee how much we
place on that local plan
it's not up to inspectors
or ultimately planning officers
to determine how we we should view
that local plan because it ultimately i
mean the local plan is very
um advanced to say it's not is
is misleading because it it's in its
final stages now where the last
modifications are being done to it
so how can you not place a lot of weight
on that local plan whether we agree with
everything that's in there is a
different story but ultimately we've got
to work with the policies we've got
and as far as i'm concerned it needs to
have weight put on it because it's in
its final stages
so i don't understand why that
particular appeal that's been
allowed has been highlighted yet the
other one two three
and the ones we've had in the past are
not being highlighted when they have
place weight
i feel like i'm being railroaded if that
makes sense
i agree entirely with that with council
chipman uh chair that
it is for the decision maker to place
weight as appropriate on the
policies of the emerging local plan
that the starting point has to be as
ever that decisions are made
on the basis of the development plan as
is so that's your extent local plan
and weight can be attributed as
appropriate to the policies of the
emerging local plan and that
that still stands chair and yes it is a
matter for the planning committee to
weigh
in making their decision the only uh
point i'm making seeking to make chairs
the
inspector in the homewood decision
took the views that she did for the
reasons set out in that report
and just seeking to advise members going
forwards chair that as the
plan does achieve greater
weight through its progress through the
stages that will need to
be addressed by members and will seek to
advise members of that chair as we move
forwards
one other point chair i was going to
make on the the home would appeal if
there's nothing else at this uh this
stage chair
oh councillor shipman's got his hand up
thank you chad
do we actually know what percentage the
uh local plan is complete as of yeah are
we at like what
are we halfway through are we 90 of the
way through
are we 99 of the way through because
we're being asked to place weight on
something we don't actually
we don't actually know how complete it
is i mean i've had i've never been
briefed on
local plan and where it's at so do you
have a
a figure or you know what stage
this chair that would be followed by the
inspector's letter
on the local plan and the council then
need to consider
any comments or recommendations made by
the inspector in that letter
and then ultimately move towards the the
very final stages of the plan
and ultimately adoption so it's getting
on in on in the process
chair but there are certain hurdles and
consultations yet to be completed
thank you any other questions
uh councillor armature just indicating i
think chair thank you
uh thank you chair it's just uh
where does the uh neighbourhood plans
where do they fit into this uh
scenario uh i mean
it's just a bit like blind leading the
blind
at the moment and the mppf
seems to be the the sort of
fail safe that we can
look at but even so that uh
says that it's our decision what would
you do
and the problem is that if they
say if we go against and turn it one
down
and it goes to appeal then we're likely
to
be faced with i mean if the pills
dismiss
if it's allowed i mean we're gonna have
an enormous bill
no doubt we've uh got one on this latest
one
okay just answering the the point that
council armpits made in respect of
neighborhood plans if they are if
they've gone through the referendum
stage chair and been
accepted in referendum at that stage
they achieved full weight
in terms of the weight that can be
attached to them however
chairs with all um plans and policies
they need to be in conformity with the
national planning policy framework
so that's always the background to to
any policy
in any plan whether it be a neighborhood
plan or a local plan but you would hope
that
certainly in terms of the council's own
local plan when it's adopted
it will achieve that full weight being
conformity with the framework
or be it it's in conformity with the
2012
framework role and the most up-to-date
so there will be certain policies in
there that
will need to be cross-checked with the
with the framework even from that
point of adoption but the point of
cancer armitage makes in terms of
neighborhood plans chairs it's full
weight
unless those policies in the
neighborhood plan aren't in conformity
with the framework and the framework yes
it does take precedence
just the final point i was just going to
make in respect of mr rich's appeal
chair is the comments that the inspector
makes in terms of the
technical matters and again members will
have read the
appeal documents i'm sure but the
inspector goes to each of those in some
detail it's interesting that
as we discuss often at committee chair
on the technical matters
it's a matter of evidence in terms of
how those issues await
in respect of the appeal the the
inspector told the view that
evidence was submitted such that all
those technical matters were satisfied
sharing and we as decision makers also
need to
er that in mind on those technical
matters such as highways
um ecology flooding etc etc where we
have many debates in committee about
themselves
thank you those are the points i was i
was going to make you happy to take any
further questions on
that appeal in particular or any of the
others
any further questions
thank you members do we agree to note
the report
um i believe this can be done in various
ways either by a vote or a roll call
um alan or just by acclimation if
members feel comfortable just noting the
report
i've got two hands up i think at the
moment i've got alan powell
and jane barry i think that's just
general acclimation am i
right on that members fine that's great
everybody happy with that you just know
the report yes chair i think members are
happy
thank you we can move on to item
five which is the section 106 legal
agreement
this is again an update and i would like
to ask the planning manager to explain
this to us and i suggest that we let him
run through
the report and then at the conclusion of
his comments i'll open the floor for
questions and discussion
and then many members will have seen
reports
of this ilk before and the
latest report i'm afraid is late because
we were due to report
the start of this year unfortunately as
we all realize events have taken rather
an unusual course so
apologize to chair for the lateness of
this report it is
and has been our intention to report on
approximately six monthly basis two
members
on 106 agreements and as the report set
out chair
it's to allow members to be aware of
section 106 agreements legal agreements
that are
local to them necessarily and or and
others of course chair but also
to keep up to date with that and also
and be party to how and when monies are
spent within of course the framework of
the
106 agreement that is set out how that
money's too spent
the report chair just sets out where we
are
with the 106s and identifies that there
are two
appendices to the report appendix a
chair identifies money that has been
collected and which is due to be spent
and as we set out in the reported
traffic lights the spending of that
money
to seek to ensure that where we have the
money it's spent within the time frame
set out
in the legal agreements
traffic lights red amber and green as
you'd expect and there are four
red cases that have been highlighted in
the report chair
we do appreciate where they all are and
two of them aren't
significantly time and bounds but
two at tupton and ekington chair are
and on one we've achieved a um
informal three-month extension to
spending that money to february 2021
that's the other share the eckington one
and we haven't yet
achieved that an extension on spending
of that money both the
cases have come into problems with
spending the money due to the
the code with pandemic and the problems
that that's caused
however officers and as appropriate the
parish councils are aware of the need to
deal with the the money in a timely way
and colleagues and in street scene in
particular are working with the parish
councils to
to do that hopefully within the
extensions or if not we'll see further
but it's
um not incumbent on the developer to
agree to those extensions if they don't
don't wish to just in terms of appendix
b
chair that sets out all the monies that
are um waiting for collection
further to develop that is either taking
place now or has taken place
or will take place and that allows us to
keep a total a running token on what we
are
looking for and where we need to be
following that up
it's important chair to note that the
onus is not on the council
to go seeking the money the onus within
the agreement
on the developer to pay us the money and
tell us when
the money is due and when the
developments reach certain milestones
but
unfortunately um it's often left to the
council to to pursue that
and i'm sure members will note that in
terms of appendix b
we are currently i'm catching up on
monitoring
those developments and we'll need to
pursue those
as we go go forward but i can advise
members that
yes we are bringing that schedule up to
date
so that we can pursue the monies where
approach and where the
various triggers have been met or or in
some cases
passed but say just to emphasize that
the
onus is not on the council to go seeking
that money
actually it's a requisite of the
developer to to pay the money
and tell us when the money is due to be
paid as well so
um it is quite significant task for us
to go around all the sites and
get the work today but we are in the
process of doing that
chair i don't know if jim's got anything
further to add
to that chair and have to take any
questions as appropriate
okay jim um
there's a couple of points in relation
to the
the first appendix the um
the monies that we've received and that
need to be spent
um there is i think adrian referred to
an amount
of in relation to eckington i think
there's a is it
8 000 pounds adrian that
used to be spent spent by genuine well i
took a call from council renick
about an hour ago and she's
confirmed that the uh this relates to
a provision of play facilities and that
those
uh play facilities will be uh provided
by
um sometime in december so the money
will be spent or she says the money will
be spent
prior to the deadline for spending the
money in january
okay thank you councillor shipman yeah
um
as it happens i'm actually chairing the
working group for tupton parish council
that's dealing with that one
um that one should be spent before
february i would have thought
uh because we've just engaged the
contractor and stuff just
to start work as soon as they can i
think they've got a bit of a backlog at
the minute
this was um this was in relation to an
eckington
place base that i was referring to yeah
yeah sorry i i i was just talking about
the other the other one that's
kind of red line at the minute well i
think the talk tomorrow needs spending
by february i think with the extension
that's just been secured
um but i suspect that like i said that
one should be
um done in time fingers crossed
just just on the top to one if i may
briefly chair i'm grateful to the
the developer for agreeing to give us
some flexibility in that and
without that would have been much more
difficult so in this case it's
very cooperative in helping us to
achieve a solution
mindful of the issues that the parish
council and others have had in getting
money spent
thank you councillor armitage is
indicating chair sorry
i've got councillor armitage councilman
foster but jim did you want to come in
there
yeah i just wanted to add um in relation
to the monies that we've
we we still have to receive that there
are a number of issues
in relation to recovery of um some of
the section 106 monies
and probably one of them um
will uh will require a um a further in
uh in-depth report to planning committee
uh explaining the issues but but
the main issue is that um
the uh the company that built the houses
this is in
um morton company that built the houses
that is actually
um dissolved and is no longer in
existence and there are issues regarding
the the recovery of that money
which needs to be discussed at a further
meeting is fairly complicated i don't
really want to go into the
details at this stage but this and i
need to bring a further report to
brandon kennedy for a uh for a decision
thank you councillor armitage uh
it was really uh uh i'd heard about this
uh situation in martin
uh and i understand that the
uh people have been billed uh something
like
10 grand each because oh
andrew's telling me difference now
right i can i can confirm that one of
the options
is potentially to build the the
residents
the individual residents uh and that's
basically is that one of the decisions
that the uh council needs to
needs to take uh do we because there is
there's no one else to
seek the money from the only people to
to
to seek their money from are the um i
think there's nine
uh owner occupiers and however that
that is the decision of the council or
which would need to come to you
initially for a decision and then
probably
with a proper recommendation for you to
consider
there just seemed to be an awful lot of
money outstanding
yes it's 130 000.
all right no no sorry 113 000
right okay thank you
councillor foster uh thank you chair uh
council foster ward member
it's the first time i've looked at these
106
sheets and being parted
risk to the council is a failure to use
so many receipt by it within the given
time scales
and from that we've then got this
traffic light system which i know works
in
other areas as well the traffic light
system of the council
um i would have thought uh just as
perhaps a lay person first off that this
would have been more appropriate a
traffic light system having this
on the money that is yet to come in
rather than the money we've got to spend
now i realize there might be some
difficulty in arranging that
but as i look at this this is not that
to me
it doesn't look that transparent to
document we've got the totals
within the three columns with all the
cases where we've got the money in
uh amount received spent to date and
current balance
and then we've got uh the traffic light
system
after that and it's all quite easy to
understand
in the further appendices
uh payments not yet due received we've
got them
not yet due and received together it
seems there
and then there's no clear it doesn't
look clear in each case there's no clear
columns to how much is due
now while i understand that might not be
an exact amount it might
in all cases um
i would have expected a column there
somewhere there where we had an
approximate amount
um and especially for the ones that are
due now
there's some there and uh there's quite
a few
uh whether it says due now and the date
when it was due and there's still no
amount there so there's
there's not great deal of information
there so for me
what i would have liked to see and um
and i like explanation not just from
offices but perhaps from what other
members
feel about this um about the clarity
it's very clear and it's very easy to
look at
uh those payments received and spent
today and i've been that
i'd like uh i'd like a bit more clarity
on that because that
i know i know we've stated in this
report that the risk is on spending the
money but i think there's also
uh there's there's a risk there on
collecting the money
and i don't like it to you know be
overshadowed by wanting to spend it
if that makes any sense thanks thank you
agent you ever come back for that
yes jeff um if council foster and other
members would like that information i
see no reason why
that can't be provided we do hold it but
the
the background documents to the the two
appendices that
are in the pack are um
pretty um full on with the information
so
um up to this point chair we've just set
out and what the headlines were but i
can understand
why councillor foster would wish to have
that additional information and
unless there is some reason why that
shouldn't be disclosed and as far as i'm
aware all 106 agreements are in the
public domain anyway
there's no reason why that shouldn't be
provided to members and i'm i'm
perfectly happy either to bring the
report back
um in the near future with that
information
or to bring that in approximately six
months time at the next
due reporting stage to provide that
information i mean and tell in your
hands chair and
whether you want an interim report to
have that information
and that's that's fine otherwise six
months time is okay
happy to leave it at that chair but um i
mean i'm in your hands
you and your your colleagues chair okay
um
counselor shipment before i make a
decision on that
yeah i agree with council foster it's
not very transparent when things are
edited out
um so i wonder if we could have the uh
risk categories that are also next to
the amount received
so if it's not been received within a
certain time so we have two
because we need to obviously know what
the risk is of spending it but also have
the
column of the risk categories of when we
receive it
so we know if it's coming or not or just
have a column that says
um you know a mountain dew
or amount i would an amount do
we could certainly um provide the amount
due chair that
that's that's relatively straightforward
to provide it and
it's how much information that's um
the members want ultimately chair and
happy to provide as much information as
is appropriate to say all the 106
agreements fall on the public
so it's not as if any of that
information is classified or not in the
public domain in any case
so it is all um transparent and
available to be viewed share in our case
if members would like more information
in terms of those amounts
in the report then we can do that
and that's relatively straightforward
it's
understanding what members would like in
terms of a traffic light system cherries
is a bit more
difficult just talking on the hoof here
because it will depend on the status of
the developments
to when that monies becomes available
um for us to collect in terms of the
number of houses that are built on any
particular site for example
but i say i'm happy to provide whatever
information
that members feel they they need to
effectively monitor the
agreements chair thank you councillor
reader then councillor ridgeway
yeah i agree with the two councillors i
think we do need it
to be more clear um also what i would
like to see and
i hope um other members would support it
as well is that end column
within the payments not yet do you
receive does
it just says date contributions chased
and i think that really would be better
if it was more of an action column
so rather than it being called date
contributions changed it it seems more
appropriate to have an actions column in
there
and maybe task it to somebody i don't
know how you do that adrian within your
department in terms of monitoring
um but certainly would sort of make it
more clear for me as a member to see
that as
what actions are being taken and who is
tasked with monitoring that as well
counselor ridgeway
oh she's gone
you're muted yeah okay sorry about that
and yeah i agree with everything that
the other councillors have said
just one thing i wanted to note to go
back to jim
um you've talked about this eight
thousand pounds the eckington parish
council
still have agreed to spend my only
concern is that as
as the representative on this committee
for the eckington area
um as like most plant of our committee
members represent the the areas that you
know
for planning it would have been nice if
there'd have been some consultation
with that ward me you know with that
with that committee member
about um you know whether the parish
council or the town teams are
spending this money because it's not
just about
the parish councils it's about
ultimately the whole of the
you know the um the district as well so
i think there should be somewhere there
in you know that um committee member not
maybe not so much the ward member but
maybe the planning committee member
should be notified of this so that they
can have some consultation either with
yourselves
the planning you know the the officers
or
you know ward members
adrian just to point on that
chair is that the 106
is in almost all cases a time where
he's very concise and clear in what the
money is to be spent on
and the money has
to be properly evidenced to be sought in
the first place
is there to mitigate a specific
implication of any development
so often there is very little discretion
share
on where and how the money is to be
spent
i've absolutely no no problems share
with elected members being involved in
all elements of the the planning process
that's
uh that's what we we're here for that's
that's the inherent
quality of the planning process its
openness and its transparency
the opportunity to frame and work
in terms of section 106 agreements is
during the application process
chair and therefore i'd urge all members
to
be involved in the evolution of the
development at an application stage
chair
because after the event the opportunity
to
mold how the money spent is often lost
and that would be my my response share
to to council ridgeway in this case
that um i get i've personally no
problems with um
involving members at any stage of the
playing process but often the
opportunity
post-decision is not there to
as i say mold or direct where specific
monies are spent
okay counselor each way do you want to
come back and then
yeah okay i i don't actually agree with
that
adrian because i know there have been
instances where this one for instance
i think other decisions had been made at
the time of the 106 agreement
and we've been pushed from pillar to
post and arguments were given
i just feel a little bit you know
aggrieved that you know we don't always
have time
to sort of it's a public realm that
could mean anything
i think there needs to be some more
specifics on that as well
um i i just find it you know
we're not always there at the planning
stage
we're not always there you know for the
106 agreements
uh and i think there should be some you
know more consultation and i think you
know we should
have that that sort of ability to be
able to say
in this district i feel this is
important we've had lots of arguments
over this money
and and that and
okay i'm happy where it's going but i
think it could have been dealt with far
sooner um
at an earlier stage okay so
i'm just putting my point of view across
thank you councillor foster then
councillor barry
thank you chair uh first of all just to
reply to
uh comments made by uh council shipment
um yeah i think we're on the same page
when it comes to what we're saying about
um about how the information should be
shown
uh the 106 information but uh certainly
not that it's been edited out i didn't
mean that for one
maybe it's not the information has not
been included but not that it's been
edited out i know the information is all
there and it's all available and it's
all public
um but just that it should be presented
in a way where we can easily look at it
and understand
it and see which direction we're going
in so that's that's that point
um next one out of all the information
that we've passed on and what possibly
uh
other councillors and this this uh this
committee
matt won i'd be happy to propose that uh
the chair took that information away
and uh those considerations are away and
discuss them with officers and see how
uh you know it could be made to see what
we're looking for so i'd be happy that
the chair discussed it with our
officers and i'd be happy to propose
that
thank you also thatcher thank you
councillor barry
[Music]
councillor barry wayne sorry um
yeah that man's just a quick question
really i i'll
sort of agree with what everybody else
is saying around the changes but
i was just asking how often is it that
we actually get this report
of 106 is coming to planning do we get
it annually
monthly isn't it adrian it is uh six
monthly chair as i say we were due to
report in march and
sadly events overtuckers chen as you
know during the summer we've had
difficulty with withholding and then um
having appropriate lengths of committee
so that's the reason why it's come back
at this point
as uh in discussion with itself other we
did think it was appropriate
um at this committee rather than and
perhaps elsewhere because it does
allow us in view of the business being
being limited to have this
sort of discussion chair so it is um
ideally and our intention and an
agreement that we've had groups with
planning committee that we report every
six months but
again share that's a matter for
yourselves if you would
like updates more regularly then
and that's fine the only issue comes
then chair in terms of
we're only monitoring currently every
six months
so the information may change um only
marginally perhaps interim as it stands
at the moment with our with our current
work practices
this is six monthly chair and just
if i can just um just mention one up for
the point um
to council ridgeway was discussing chair
part of the
background to providing this information
to members
albeit at the moment on a six monthly
basis is so that members can monitor
and understand what monies there are in
the 106
part and what we're expecting and how
they're
going to be paid so the one of the
intentions of this report was to
facilitate that involvement with elected
members chair but again if
the discussions that we have further to
council the foster suggestion chair
the conclusions are that additional or
alternative information is appropriate
then we can
facilitate that chair and bring reports
back as necessary
thank you councillor barry and i think
we'll round it up
yeah um i think i mean i'm finding this
meeting quite useful i assume everybody
else's as well
and i think with the one or six months i
mean i'd like to see
if we could on a quarterly basis i'm not
saying we're going to get that straight
away but i think if we had a
quarterly review of this that would
benefit us but i also
feel that having a meeting like this at
least
twice a year would also be beneficial
so that we're we're on top of where
we're going um and that would perhaps
alleviate some of the issues that are
coming up
so you know uh once i've back what
council foster's saying i think we
should be looking at
perhaps increasing the you know the the
times that we get to meet to actually
discuss this properly
and to increase the frequency of the
report to quarterly rather than
half half yearly okay
um i'm quite happy to move with both
council of fosters and councillor
shipman's recommendation i think that'd
be quite a useful exercise and
counselor barry would you like to be
part of that as well
as vice chair yes please thank you
um if there are no more questions uh
bring
counselor parts
counselor parts yeah um can i just ask
at this point is it is it relevant for
um questions on specifics on this grid
or
do you want to make the decision um as
proposed and then we can
move on to discuss other issues or are
we not allowed to to discuss specifics
adrian do you want to discuss specifics
here or later
the latest section can't hear you adrian
yes my apologies chair um happy to to go
either way
chair the the problems with specifics is
um i may not be able to answer them here
and now maybe a matter of having to get
back to
members on the chair but happily answer
questions as i can and if i can't
i'll i can write to members answering
queries on specifics okay counselor pots
can we do specifics because we've got
other people
going to join us for the next section to
cover different questions on 106s and it
might be relevant to them as well
yeah i'm happy to do it then not not any
problem i just didn't want to miss the
opportunity
definitely not just just briefly if i
may chair any
any member at any time if you have
queries on
106 agreements spending of money then
feel free to approach us and we'll help
or find out answers
it's often a matter of discussion with
colleagues in street scene housing
the county council etc who are all
spending bodies rather than us as
planners but happy to discuss and
provide information on any 106 at any
time chair it doesn't need to be through
the formal
process of a planning committee thank
you
so firstly and this is the conclusion so
is everyone happy with the proposals
that's been put forward by a councillor
fostering council shipment
for us so can you just have a quick show
of hands okay can we just be clear
what the proposal is so it's for the
chair and vice chair in these
circumstances then to actually uh
discuss with officers the concerns
raised by members on section 106 matters
yes and the ways forward yeah and is
that
in addition then to the other three
recommendations which are in the uh
substantive text of the report which is
effectively
to note the information in appendix a
and b
um to actually note and endorse um the
information in 1.6 i think
in the report itself and to actually try
for half yearly meetings although that
might now change
yeah is everyone happy with that
okay show of hands please
all members seem to be contenture lovely
thank you
thank you very much um item six is
urgent business
i've no urgent business so i now declare
this meeting closed however i would
remind you that with
members there is a cinema for section
106
process which will take parts about 10
minutes after this alan
yes i think that's it we'll just give
members a chance and to actually enter
the
virtual room thank you thank you chad
will this change
at this end alan uh no i think if
members sorry counselor pal did you wish
to
i'm gonna say do we have zoom details
for the next one it'll be in this room
so basically people will now join
this room now that the meeting's
finished alan could i have someone to
come and take this big white box
off the screen for me please um we'll
try and have a word with
louise gascoigne and get that sorted for
your chair
you